Hello everybody, My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Astroneer.
Soo, apparently...I don't know when this happened,
but it just suddenly decided that the printer wanted to work
and I have the necessary stuff for it
no I do not - OH
OH
Oh! YES!
That's awesome! - ONE seat?
one seat for what? One seat for who?
I don't know, But apparently this is able to be utilized now
so I need to go out and get this sorta stuff
the only problem is I don't have a lot of compound
and compound seems to be
the one thing I need a lot of
and I don't know...
I don't know if its just lying around
or anything but I don't have enough oxygen
to be able to go down into the caves just yet
so now I'm in a sprint
a mad sprint-
Oh oxygen! Perfect
Okay so now
I'm just gonna be in a mad sprint to be able to get the necessary materials that I need
and also explore a little bit farther out into the landscape.
I don't know why  oxygen is just sitting in giant blue puddles here,  but
that's kinda cool and convenient
What is that?! OH what is that?
What is that?!
WHAT IS THAT??
Is that a tornado? Is that a HaBOOB?
Oh god no, that's so awesome! Oh no!
Matt Damon help me!
Oh what the fucking fuck?
That's so cool!
Also I, oh my god oh oh oh
oh my god, oh my god! Ah! oh my god!
okay, I'm out of here, I gotta get back. AH!
Fuck my head
Oh oh oh my god I'm dead
Whaa I just died?!
Well that's fucking deadly
Don't destroy my base!
Oh no I like this base!
Don't do that! That's so awesome!
and terrifying!
what the fuck? That's so cool!
That can just happen?! At any time?
What happens if I'm way out in the distance?
Do I have to try to find shelter?
Do I have to just immediately start digging in the ground
so rock doesn't break my brain open?
Oh thats so cool
How long does it last?
How long am I going to be  sitting here?
Well I guess, I just got to wait it out
I'm not going to go out in that mess- oh
I think it might be passing over. Yeah
Yeah
That is nuts! That's nuts!
That's just bonkers! And they used up all of my oxygen
Oh I lost all of my materials
Ooooh, theres my dead body
well good thing we've got infinite cloning devices
Oh that's so cool
I did not make it far, I did not do that
Oh my god what if, what if theres just a body there?
What if I am literally a reproduced clone?
Oh my god there
Oh no
Well that didn't help me
But ye yeah there is a body
That is, that is a body!
That is a body!!
I'm a different person than that was
Oh my god they just vanished! Oh no and I'm out of oxygen
Oh god no!
What are the implications of that?
I'm another clone? Am I even human?
What does that mean? What am I?
Do I even want to know?
Are there some questions that are-- WHAT IS THAT?
What the fuck is that? Is that a planet?
Da fuck?
Okay. Alright then.
Wow. I am so confused.
So th.. the other thing that I've noticed is
almost nothing needs organic
so there must be something else that I can make
that would be able to do what I need it to do
but for right now I'm going to go in the direction
that I've built this exploration because that seems to be
the most readily available for me to do
what I need to do, and I need to find a lot more Resin
I- there was a deposit of Resin around here somewhere
anyway I'm sure that I could just dig in the ground and probably find some stuff
but I don't have enough power to do that
dig willy nilly
I don't have enough oxygen just to be able to go anywhere I want to
What is that...? Is that an oxygen fountain?
That might be an oxygen fountain
I'm not 100% sure about that
but if that's what it is- Oh Resin hello!
I'll take all of you! That is so much Resin..
YES PLEASE! Thank you!
Why's it gotta be night literally all the time?
But if that's an oxygen fountain- which I'm gonna need, like IMMEDIATELY,
Because I'm running out of oxygen... again...
That is gonna be cool
Oh that is cool. Gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
Gimme GIMME - Thank you!
God dammit no POWER??? But I need the oxygen!!
God, I am in trouble
There's a little bit... Oh, man, I haven't even had enough to fill up another batch of oxygen
I've just had enough to fill up my bar right now
There's gotta be some power around here somewhere....
Man, I had no idea that there were like, risks of death like that
No wonder there are so many crashed ships around here
There's probably a lot of bodies buried underneath this place.
Ah! There's a power font.
Okay, so power right there.. Then go back for the oxygen
C'mon c'mon c'mon-- Gimme- Yay!
Ya ya ya ya YA!
AY YAY YA YA YA!!!!!
Gimme! Gimme! Don't...
Don't.. Don't look at me, I'm not.. I'm being an idiot right now
Okay, so I go back and I get the oxygen, because I'm almost out of that
I probably need to dump this
and dump this, because I can get organic stuff literally anywhere
but what I need right now is oxygen
please, please, gimme gimme gimme gimme
HA YA YA YA YA
Oh no, it's not enough! OH GOD
This is not enough! Well, that was a wasted opportunity, but at least I got some resin.
I'll be able to get some resin on the way back, and that should be everything that I actually needed to get while I was out here
Got it, got it, get it- okay.
That's pretty full- uh- do I need some compound? yes
maybe? maybe maybe baby? what i'll do is
i'll drop the power right here, bring the
compound back because i need two of these.
Fuckin running out of oxygen!!!
This is bad fucking god dammit are you are
you fucking kidding me?? come on!!! COME ON!!!!
there we go!!! GO!! GO!! fucking are you
kidding-a- me?!?!
Oh i gotta make it to the oxygen AH! about to
sufft-a-cate! At least I got resin....
we're ok then we got it okay that was
good and dangerous and deadly and I
shouldn't have done that but I did it
anyway
ok so i got a lot of resin what else can
I make with resin got comp... what the fuck
was that do why what did that come from
I didn't have this I- i was full up on
stuff i'll put you right there for now
hold on I'm, I was very confused by the...
titanium copper I can make a beacon but
I don't need that. Solar power I could
make another one of those that would be
kind of nice. It just be kind of nice to
have that on my back at all times so
that i get double the power whenever I
needed and then I'd be less power in
general so take this compound put it
there again that away so that is
something, oh boy alright.
So i need to go find stuff to
apply more research to be able to pay
and make more designs and i'm pretty
sure that i would only be able to get
the research materials out of the wrecks
around the area and i would like to go
that way i want to go that way but I
don't I- haven't I-haven't built up my stuff
to go in that direction yet. I'm gonna
build a storage container because I
think i would actually kind of like that
because if i can go out and get a bunch
of material then keep it in storage then
I should have more than enough and I don't have a way to do that
oh oh god dammit I'm so good at lifting things with my brain.
man is it's just really interesting the way that everything is constantly looking at me
like these are always pointed in the direction that I am
like just the level of technology here is kind of amazing.
So how do I? OH! Now that's handy that
right so I'm gonna build this out a bit more
Shubady boop ta boo-boo, Shubady boop ta boo-boo
You think that I would be able to make some sort of oxygen creation device but...
I guess this is just a standard limitation on what this is
bo-ba-do I think that might have been the last of my resin. Yes it was.
Ok so I'm out of resin but this gives me a bit more flexibility be able to go farther out.
Um- I went that way I'm gonna go the opposite direction this time and try to go over there.
Just touch up my oxygen and here we go. Let's hope I find some oxyo-ja
'cause if I don't I'm going to be dead.
Doodly-doo doodly-doo
What is that over there
I think it's power but I don't need that need oxygen.
Does anybody want to give me some oxygen out here?
I'm alone and- what the fuck is that?
What's with the giant yellow bricks? WOAh
What is this another cave? Oh boy! Oh oxygen in there.
Ohh- and something else in there. I don't know what that is but I'm about to find out.
Oh yay! Okay good yeah- That... that's concerning.
Oh n... Oh oh oh my god, oh no oh no!
Hey okay okay that is that is a 100%...
Why... What the fuck was that?
Seriously the fuck was that? I have no idea! Okay going down here.
Ouch my ass! I also want to mention, I don't think I've talked about this...
Whoa... aluminum ore. Oh cool! I need a smelter to be able to do this but that's good.
So I want to mention, um, I really like the way that there is no user interface in this game.
I... it was... it was almost I didn't even notice it at first but there literally is no interface anywhere here
It's not aparent because... Oh shit oh shit oh shit.
Hydrazine, need you! Oh Shit.
I have too much oxygen so what i can do is...
I will leave some behind because I don't need that much.
Let me take the hydrazine because I do need fuel. I'm assuming I do anyway
and then there's a whole bunch of other stuff... Oh my god, this terrifying. Oh no this is... this is horrifying.
This is horrible. Oh my god I don't want to go down here.
There's got to be a way I can make like a jet pack or something because... Ooooh!
Malachite?! What is malachite?
I don't know but I'll take it. I'll put it in storage if I don't need it.
I'm just going to make sure that I can actually get out of here.
I need a full sac... Ah fuck! Okay stop going that way. Why was it pulling me in? That was fucking weird!
Okay either way, I'm out here baby. Try not to fall down deeper in this game of death.
I'm really hoping that there aren't secretly alien life forms literally... I fucking what the fuck was that?
The fuck... is that? The fuck is that?! Grab you but I'm not happy about it- Oh that is horrifying!
Ok the only problem is I can't jump.
Fucking god damn it! Get back here. No you're not getting away from me whatever you are.
Ah, stop it. Ah, stop it. You're so weird. Ah, what is it?
I don't like the fact that it has spindly arms.
You stay there. Don't roll!
Heee!
Oh fuck me! Ouch. God damn it I'm out of oxygen aren't I? Good thing there's some more right here.
Gimme gimme-gimme-gimme
It's harder than I thought it would be to navigate.
You gotta have some sort of, like, Jetpack that you can make for yourself to get out of here because
otherwise navigating this was impossible
I mean not impossible. I guess anything's possible when you're able to carve an entire mountains out.
With a freaking space gun.
Will I have enough oxygen to be able to get out of here?
It's gonna to be close it's gonna be real close especially with this.
I have some oxygen here. Why wasn't I using it?
Because it just wasn't enough for a stack of it.
You know what? I'm gonna cheat a little bit. I think I can skedaddle a bit
by just dropping this forward. Oh my god! What is that? Are those eyeballs is that it's ass?
So weird when i asked that question:
1- I didn't know I have to ever have to ask that question my life.
And number 2- It's weird that i don't know the answer.
Is that his eyeballs are its ass is this alive or what is this?
I got it! I got a prize, mom. You happy with me? You're gonna put this on the fridge?
Right thanks mom sorry actually
oh god! I'm very sorry, actually. I'm sorry did this. Didn't meen to.
Just gonna put this on a...  Fucking stop that Jesus it's getting...
Alright okay alright. Popping it on. There we go!
I don't know what to do then. Go for it, I guess
Okay.
What the fuck is this is that? The fuck was that? What is that?
Research truck
Okay
I can make a truck now? Can I make a truck?
Winter mind, battery, generator, one seat, solar panel. Nope! Can't make it there anyway.
Why...? What the fuck it that?
I don't know what it's talking about. Either way, I'm gonna put
I can make some aluminum but I need to make a smelter, I know that. to make a smelter i know that.
Ah. I need to make another one of these which means I need to met... I need to get more resin.
So, I'm going to put some stuff in storage right here.
Hydrazine and malachite that goes in.
So, I've got the malachite and the aluminum in storage there and I'm gonna go out ans try to find more resin
and if i'm not mistaken this plenty of resin over there.
So I need more resin to be able to make another one of these things. Which can make me another...
Another, another thing to build another building like I built the printer and I built the researcher.
So i need to build another building like that.
And I spy oxygen on the horizon which is gonna be great.
Which means that i can go out and explore and get whatever I need.
I need compound and I need resin.
I wonder if I just dig straight down if I'd be able to find everything that I need.
Will I tap into a cave system eventually.
I imagine I would right. And if I had all the power than I need  there's really no worry or concern.
I would just... have everything
Am I not mistaken here compound. Thanks
Thanks thanks thanks, thank you thanks
thanks thanks thanks
Whoo! Hello? Whoo pre-made things. Yes please. Okay good.
Whoa, did this crash here? Well how does that thing still have power?
That's crazy! Oh pre-made aluminum, oh yes! Copper hell yes. Lithium, hell yes! All of those things.
whoa and a one-seater i'm assuming that is.
Ok. You know what? I'm gonna... I'm gonna hold on to that because this is a research thing.
So if I take this... and bring it back with me, I should be...
I don't know what that is too but... whatever that, it's cool. But I gotta bring this back because I get my research out of it.
So once i get this research thing in the research pod, I should have some resien.
No I didn't get any resident i'm an idiot.
All right pop this in the old... in the old research facility here do we have enough power?
No we don't because we don't have any solar power because the Sun is literally never out.
Can the Sun actually you know rise?  Little more if...  Oh there we go thank you!
That's delightful. I feel like it's been night forever.
Ok so there's not enough power to be able to do research, at least not yet.
I could add one of my solar panels there but i'm not going to do that.
While the sun is up I'm gonna take advantage of this energetic fact and I'm gonna try to...
I'm literally gonna try to carve down as deep as i can
just because I like digging holes in the ground. I'm... I just kind of want to see what I can do
As far as getting down in the earth.
Oh, that's right. When I go down far enough there won't be any solar power.
Oh, that's right. Do I hear the wind blowing?
Oh no oh no oh no sprint sprint
buddy ohhh run run run run run run run
run
Do not die!
whoo boy whoo baby whoo baby whoo baby
Ok, do I have enough time to put my stuff on the storage rack?
Maybe I do. Be quick about it, be quick about it. Put it... put it on. I don't care to put it on put it on
Oh boy! Gotta get in, gotta get inside
gotta get inside. Ok! Getting inside, getting inside, now, now. Oh boy, not that.
Hey! That was close.
Ok so we've made a lot of progress. We've got a lot of materials and we got an idea
for what we need to do in the future. But the only thing we don't have, is more resin
and then we haven't researched this thing.
But we're gonna hold off the storm...  can't close... close the damn door?!
Like maybe it would be smart not to be right in the way of all the blasting.
You know. I know you want some fresh air while you're in there but maybe it wouldn't be a would be too bad of an idea.
Good thing we got the printer in our way.
But either way, that's all the time I gought for this episode. Hope you guys are enjoying this because I certainly am
This game is delightful and amazing and I love it. And i haven't even scratched the surface on it.
Literally I have not. I want to see if there's a way to get the fuck
like to a different location like
if I can make a vehicle or something like I should be able to do all sorts of shit.
But not just yet. So thank you everybody so much for watching for watching and as always I will see you...
you in the next video
Buy-Bye!